these are pajama jeans it's just like a
bell bottom II flare cut which is not in
ever I already like this these are the
nicest jeans I own are the ones I'm
wearing now until I try these on I feel
like a brand new lady honestly these
kind of feel kind of shitty drawstring
just hanging out so I get Brett Farve
and a pair of these throwing a football
around in the backyard but like they fit
my I don't know if we can get that the
but this fake fly is really weird
they are probably the comfiest things
that I've ever been on my legs I'm glad
they've got the one little secret pocket
that jeans have you can slide a gum ball
in there for later
I will be honest I'd probably never wear
these around another person
wham-o hoverball yeah it does it's like
the worst it smells like if chocolate
took a [ __ ] so you just kick it across
the ground ah where's the fun in that
okay I guess it's actually pretty cool
when we just kick like a paper plate
around you know what else moves across
the floor even better a ball yeah
they're roll I hear ya
how many times have you been in your
house thinking I wish I could kick the
soccer ball under this couch do you have
like extra strength in your floor she's
worried he'll she's wearing this armoire
this is such a bad idea so then where do
you put your hands exactly guess it's
okay it's a terrible strain on the
wrists
yeah I'd much rather be holding the
couch and then just do the regular way
yeah boom you know that broken wrists
are the most common emergency room
emergency according to my dad skater
friend I thought this was a vibrator
when he first handed it to me like a
drill put the wax in your ear pull the
wax here here we go but isn't it sick
like as it's disgusting that good and so
like technically I should have like
clean ass years after this right if a
q-tip is bad for you how bad is this for
you animate this is doing anything I'm
not even convinced that it's doing
anything other than making a noise I
don't know how much of it is sucking it
out or it's just the fact I stuck it in
my ear that either means this is really
bad or it means that no wax sucking
through a straw has more suction power
than this thing they're fun commercials
right and it's interesting that you can
get the little toy that matches up with
it it's kind of like spotting a
celebrity in real life it doesn't really
matter but just like oh I saw this on TV
like it's cool like yeah it's worthless